Roy starts off this hour in Hartford
Connecticut i roy how are you
good afternoon mr. Ramsey Connecticut
wishes you well and we hope you and
yours are well well thank you sir how
can I help
uh well sir um this is kind of a
probably different situation than they
used to hear that you're all these
people who are afraid of paying the
mortgage on their second or third house
and all that and if they work for you
know god bless them um sir I suffer from
PTSD my 55 year old well and I haven't
been in the workforce for a couple of
years I do what I can
part-time most of my life I've worked
under the table so now I get I try to
live off 690 dollars a month off SSI and
I'm going to work and I'm just you know
wondering if I could ask you if there's
anything else I could do to increase my
income or you know my future looks like
I'm going to be 70 in 15 years
now I don't want to be able andros been
sitting on a park bench I'm going to
work mm-hmm you know her mr. Ramsey's
absolutely sure
so PTSD you served in the in the service
not no sir I didn't I'm not gonna
pretend that it came from a different
source on how kind of also um I've had
not the health issues going on I'm fine
but I'm log and diagnose you know major
depression and things like that but you
know I still try to work and I do good
you know blood I do home repairs
carpentry painting plumbing and all that
and I pick up odd jobs now and then but
the little tool or four hours a week I
make on top of this 690 I get from my
disability just doesn't make it and mr.
Ramsey I'm not one of those people I
don't want to run to the wall for office
or estate of lions in lying honest and
say give me free money give me a check
give me this you know I got you well the
good news is the good news is is that
you're willing
what you've got to do I would suggest
that you continue to look at
at what you're doing what you're doing
there with the odd jobs thing could
really turn into something I mean I know
I know one guy that makes about a
hundred a year doing that but he's
really grown the business he's grown his
clientele base obviously he's grown his
skills on the types of jobs he can do
but little minor repairs around the
house it's so hard to get reliable
people to do that another treasure right
the trick is is for you to be reliable
with some of the things that some of the
challenges you're facing and so the good
news about you and doing this the good
news about you being self-employed on
this is that you you're the one that's
in control if you get fired yes if you
work in a job for somebody else and you
have some of these issues pop up you get
fired you know and that's that gets you
into all kinds of problems and you cycle
in and out of Social Security and man
that can really put a pinch on you so I
would think well if I were you a
self-employed thing where you control
your destiny because you have the
initiative you've just got the
limitation of these challenges that
sneak up and bite you in the butt
sometimes right yes sir but they're non
predictable it's not consistent yeah you
know I know I don't know sometimes I'll
go like hell for a couple of months and
then some days I just can't move and yep
and so what I do what you got to do is
you have to create a thing with your
clients we're given if you have a day
you can't move that you're not leaving
some client out to dry that you promised
to get work done for and so you've got
it you got to create relationships with
the people you're doing work for that I
mean you don't have to cry you don't
have to whine about it because you're
not a whiner you've made that real plain
but just say you know sometimes I run
into some issues and I'm not able to
show up and so I need you to know that
if you know if I'm telling you I'm gonna
be here then we're gonna do this in the
next five days those five days may
stretch out over seven or those five
days may stretch out over ten and in
return for your patience I'm gonna give
you a good rate on the work that I'm
doing and the work will be done right it
just may stretch out a little bit
because I bump in
myself sometimes and just just give
yourself some wiggle room and don't set
high huge you know high expectations
that you can't meet on scheduling the
good news is is you can handle the
scheduling and then you can just sit
down with somebody if you got a problem
and look at them and go this is what I'm
facing you know give me a couple days
and I'll be right back in here you know
or whatever it is you got to do but
where you're self-employed and again the
good news is that you're doing a
handyman stuff it's just very popular to
do that kind of work and I did see the
day that you get the thing growing big
enough that maybe even you didn't need
the social security that could happen so
that would be my encouragement it's just
to continue to do that and use the
initiative that you've got the fact that
you're not lazy and that you don't want
to be on the dole and you want to try to
figure something out use that as your
driving force use that as your internal
motivation and the other thing I would
do is try to get some guys around you
maybe at your local church that walk
with you and give you just some
encouragement and also also you know the
ones that will kick in the butt and keep
you going do don't don't lose this
business you built it up don't lose it
and they just keep on you you need a
good coach in your life or two and some
good buddies around you at your local
church is a good way to do that
hey thanks for the call anytime I can
help roll you call me hey guys thanks
for watching if you enjoyed this video
click the subscribe button to get the
latest content and check out these other
great clips from the show and say you
have to break the cycle you have to flip
this thing on its head and make it
behave you've got to get so fired up and
wired up that you're broke friends think
you've lost your mind